um you turned me on to this I missed I
missed this game what is this game uh
Kinectimals kinectimals for those of you
who didn't see the trailer you can go
check it out it is a game we have a
virtual pet and there there been these
games before yeah that called um not
that you could stroke and pet and feel
we are young - off he could be like
what is it called
but 'no tell well it's now the kinect
and the kinectimals the kinect use the
Kinect to rub your TV screen and then a
baby Tigers gonna fall in love
with you this looks like the worst
thing I have a three-year-old
niece I know for a fact she wouldn't
want to play this game
she's be dissipated us no ID on the tops
of his playlist this game looks so dumb
here's okay here's the thing if they're
going to have a game like this where you
can you have your own virtual pet this
is a time where you should be able to
beat your virtual pet you should be able
to beat the out of that and now
we're going back to the fable 3 thing
Nona smack oh yeah I want to be able to
beat up endangered species I want to be
able to pick out terrible snow snow
tiger kittens that's what I want to beat
up so Tiger because the one in the
trailer is just a regular time just
regular tiger I want you wanted not
again it's not exotic enough for right
who hasn't beaten a tiger so would you
want to like rape an aardvark - this
starting to sound at least mildly
interesting like it's it's it's
all the responsibility and boredom of
having a pet on your TV it's I don't get
it I don't you don't have to like feed
it er yeah whatever
what do I okay I also don't get to touch
it now you can touch it no not in real
life it's not like I feel any textures
and then the games I get to play with it
I saw one of the games really
interesting game called balancing let's
get on a balance here I got I got news
for you I got news for you whoever are
the jackasses made this game
Tigers have perfect balance they
don't need help they don't need a sista
true from like a four-year-old you know
little girl in her living room number
one number two what kind of
family was that in that commercial it
was a weird family because it's it's
like a white woman
well they're black hid in a Chinese kid
here's the fucked-up part about all the
Microsoft commercials they're in the
same living room they are always in the
same which is like is this one house
like 16 is this a boarding house that
were filming the in I was I was
watching I think that no this does
happen with every you're right it
every with everyone because I always
watch and I tried figure out like who
are these people's relationships like
you know who are these people how do
they know each other you know cuz it's
never like I can identify one or the
other and be like you know uh that's the
father that's the mother you can't
figure that out it's horrible the
best part is at the dance central promo
trailer not the one that we watch with
the gameplay footage but the the one
where it shows the family dancing oh my
god have you seen this see this is
exactly why than one and there's a
blonde mom mm-hmm mom's got a
badonkadonk and she's just rub it all
over the kids faces as she's dancing
which is the best thing but hey
oh love it kids emotionally scarring a
money sort of meds that's Microsoft's
new thing it's like hey let's ruin child
well the way they had a frame they
didn't show the kids sitting at the
dining room table whacking it well no
they just shot the kid who's getting ass
hit into his face crying
Oh
you